welcome to this freezing cold day it was
decided to freeze think that means
really good body language we've got
paintball gun yeah most people been
asking for it you've been asking for
literally a year so we're gonna shoot
some of this today oh yeah the thing is
people guns are actually really Davis
you have to be really careful because
they could idiot so what we're gonna do
is one of us is gonna get shot in the
flesh which on a day like this is gonna
be painful anyway so with that their
flesh Oh none aren't the missile it's up
to whoever get shot where you get shot
you can do ya ass cheek and I go for
upper ass if it's me us off the point
right so it's I wouldn't tells you this
yeah tails give me that now this is
gonna hurt so much it's gonna hurt so
much revenge
yeah make sure you hit the bone yeah cuz
if we have to do this again I will go
mental okay so who knows it's not my
actual ass cheek it's just upper lower
back okay
[Music]
oh that's already always broken the skin
there look at that did it feel good for
you - yeah I bet it did
most people think as of yet slow mo guys
know the most painful thing was you
bonking me in the end of this camera
this lens actually okay
dad's getting shot in the leg real close
300
it was just like nothing nothing no
that's fine oh that's very gnarly okay
you just get those circular paper
bruises that nothing else gives you
apart from paint balls you've been table
down you yes yes that your that's my
later hurting jump dance song and dance
yeah love it well that was a painful
video I heard a lot more now than I did
yeah now that episode was shot a couple
of months ago and I totally still have
the scar so oh yeah that's pretty dumb
don't don't do that now what I want you
to do this is something you should do is
subscribed to deep sky videos it's a new
show made by Brady the guy that does
sixty symbols and periodic videos it's
very cool very interesting Channel and
I'm linking you right now to a video
about exploding stars everything you
need to know about supernova check it
out click it
[Music]
you